welcome back me Prime Minister it's on
the offensive this morning with a
warning that state pensions NHS spending
and even free bus passes could be put at
risk if Britain votes to leave the
European Union
Mr Cameron says the strain that brexit
would put on the economy would threaten
the so called triple lock guarantee for
pensioner payments and the ring fenced
health funding or joined now by Priti
Patel the Employment Minister and vote
leave campaign and a very good morning
to you so more project fear or a genuine
warning about some of the dangers oh
well look I think this is still very
much part of the remaining campaigns
approach in almost now not just the fear
aspect but terrifying people with
projections again in terms of you know
what the lists the lists that you've
just reeled off if people are asking for
you know what does leave well we've been
very clear in terms of leave the
opportunities that would be created for
our economy more trading opportunities
more economic growth more job security
control of our borders also more
importantly as well which really speaks
to some of the points the Prime
Minister's making today the fact that
would take that control of the money
that we currently give to the European
Union and we would spend that money on
how approach them just spent an awful
lot of areas that mean it's ten billion
quid I mean it doesn't doesn't cover all
the areas that the leave campaign
Invention 10 10 billion pounds it's a
substantial amount of money directly we
do not have any control over that is
British taxpayers money that we freely
and willingly give over as part of our
subscription to the European Union I
think that the British public would like
to see that money not handed over to
unelected bureaucrats and people that
are not accountable to the British
taxpayer that the British public would
like to see that money spent on people
you know the Prime Minister and the
Chancellor's argument is is that because
the overall economy would take a dip and
that 10 billion pounds would be dwarfed
by a smaller economy therefore even if
you spend the same proportion on things
like the NHS and defense and so many
other things it's a lot less money well
a couple of points to make first of all
their forecasts have all been based on
all the negative factors they've not
forecasted in for example the fact that
our economy would grow if we had the
ability to trade freely in a way in
which the European
and prevents us from doing so right now
with new partnerships trade agreements
that would enable our economy to grow in
a way in which it has not been growing
so far but also not only that I mean we
have to be you know we need to be
optimistic for the future of our country
I think all we've heard from the remain
side is the constant negativity talking
our country down you know it's such a
contrast right now this weekend you know
because they're using using experts
independent experts experts you used to
accept were independent like the the the
IMF the Institute for Fiscal Studies
you're now saying they got some
predictions wrong so they're they're
wrong about everything
well I was I was suggest actually the
IMF are not independent for a start the
ifs in governments we are constantly
arguing with the ifs basically in terms
of their numbers their forecasts and
things of that nature and yes let's be
quite clear about this the country the
British public don't want to be lectured
by organizations that quite frankly sir
10 15 20 years ago that we should join
the erm look what a success that was not
when people lost their livelihoods when
we saw exactly how our economy was
destroyed through our membership of the
RM these are the same organizations that
wanted us to join the euro well look at
what has happened to the eurozone across
the European Union and of course there
are the ones constantly trying to force
us into a political relationship a more
harmonization and integration with the
European Union but I mean we are saying
that that is not good for Britain it's
certainly not you've changed your mind
about the European Union haven't you
mean in the past you voted quite
consistently on elements for instance of
it have been larger and you used to
think that it wouldn't be a bad thing of
Turkey joined the European well it's his
government policy for Turkey
it's his government policy for Turkey to
join the European Union this referendum
in my view has changed the dynamics I
think we should have did but you never
have to think that it would be alright
if turkey eventually joined the European
policy but this referendum has
effectively thrown up very legitimate
concerns about Turkish membership of the
European Union you didn't have one when
you vote we are paying well we now
discover we've now discovered that we
are paying British taxpayers cash is
being spent on supporting Turkey's
accession to the European Union we've
now seen I think the Sunday Times of
today documents that are basically shown
that the government's were looking at
exploring the free movement of Turkish
people to the United Kingdom these are
issues that are now coming out in the
public domain and actually this debate I
would suggest actually the challenge now
is to put more of this information into
the public domain so the public can
actually see what is going on it's not
just just been looking through some of
your voting record in July 2010 you
voted to establish the European Union
external Action Service December that
year you voted to work closely with the
European Commission to deliver a strong
principle based framework for financial
sector corporate governance and then
this in 2011 you voted against requiring
a referendum prior to the UK giving
emergency financial assistance via the
EU to Member States let's discuss those
areas actually back in 2011 as well I
remember speaking during the sovereignty
bill in Parliament calling for an annual
audit actually before these directives
all the rules that are transported over
an annual report and importantly asking
for powers to be repatriated back to the
governments in Westminster we have not
seen any of that and also if I may say
fighting over money without asking too
greedy
those discussions took place prior to
the 2015 general election they took
place prior to our commitments give a
referendum they took place prior to the
renegotiation that actually did not
deliver on our own manifesto commitments
as well in terms of controlling our
borders securing our public services
making sure that people that come to the
United Kingdom actually contribute so
the emergency break that has been spoken
about still has to be negotiated these
are areas that quite frankly the British
public are concerned about we're hearing
the concerns certainly I am when I'm
travelling the country and I am going
out and about in this referendum
campaign the public want answers and
they want to know that the government is
on their side standing up for them
against the unelected and the
unaccountable institutions in the
European Union only hearing concerns
within the Conservative Party about
other the prime minister and his
acolytes are conducting the remain
campaign well all my colleagues have a
in terms of the conduct of the
referendum campaign my focus has been
obviously for the vote leave campaign
and campaign in out and about the
country and I distill my focus people
have different views you know in terms
of the two campaigns but I think
certainly from the vote leave side you
know our arguments are resonating with
the public we are out there the public
are telling us what their comments what
about Boris Johnson talking to another
MP about how to get rid of him well I
don't know the details of any of that so
I think it's an appropriate for me to
comment on that but what I would say my
colleagues I've been in Parliament this
week I've been in Westminster with my
colleagues we are focused you know on
the two campaigns whether it's remain or
leave on focusing on the arguments and
certainly from my side that is important
but also we recognize as well that after
the referendum we are a Conservative
Party in government and that we'll
continue to work together to deliver on
the various strands of our manifesto
commitment Prime Minister David Cameron
well of course absolutely I think that's
not that's not an issue so even if he
sacks you I've look I've been very clear
during this referendum campaign you've
heard the Prime Minister himself say so
as well that win or lose he will deliver
the will of the British public I support
him in that
so you think he would be the man for the
job if the leaves I prevail you think
he's the one who reluctantly then
renegotiate so I will say it again I've
been very very clear in fact I could not
be any clearer I've said this throughout
this referendum campaign he's the prime
minister he will deliver the will of the
British public on the outcome of this
referendum and quite frankly I do see
some of those sort of like you know the
leadership question that occasionally
comes up I just think that is
speculative and I think that is totally
irrelevant David Cameron is our prime
minister and will be after the
referendum okay
please Peter good to see you thank you
very much indeed